[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler eric revel
éditorialistes rt france bonsoir les
crevettes merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous à vos côtés jacques myard 1ère l
air de maisons laffitte alors c'est vrai
qu'on vient d'entendre ce reportage
assez accablant et qui nous a mis un peu
mal à l'aise il faut bien le dire sur ce
plateau de florence haye et qui parlait
de ça sa maman qui a été victime de deux
maltraitance dans deux ehpad votre
réaction chaque milliard
écoutez vous savez il faut prendre ça
avec sérieux il faut prendre ça avec
rigueur il faut écouter il peut y avoir
effectivement ce que madame maillet a
rapporté des maltraitances c'est vrai
moi même j'ai fait fermer une maison de
retraite où les patients étaient
semblait dans leur lit et nous l'avons
fermé et la société a disparu ça peut
parfaitement arriver mais il faut se
garder je dirais de généraliser car j'ai
sur ma ville quatre ou cinq résidence
ehpad et je n'ai pas de plainte il y en
a eu je viens de vous le rappeler il y a
quelques années ça remonte déjà à 7 8
ans mais aujourd'hui nous veillons et
nous sommes extrêmement attachés ça ne
veut pas dire qu'il va pas y avoir un
problème demain mais ce que vient de
rapporter mal à maillet est extrêmement
choquant cela va de soi et donc je crois
qu'il s'est tu vous savez je vous dire
cent fois sur le métier remettre
l'ouvragé on n'est sûr de rien on peut
avoir demain matin des plaintes sur une
parce qu'il ya un manquement parce qu'il
ya du personnel qui ne veut pas dire
qu'il s'est trompé et sa part en
quenouille donc il faut être extrêmement
prudent alors deux enquêtes en tout cas
on est est ouvert ce matin par le
gouvernement le pdg d'orpea sera
auditionné demain par les députés et cet
après-midi le scandale était centre de
la séance de questions au gouvernement à
l'assemblée nationale je vous propose
d'écouter notamment andré chassaigne
député communiste qui a interpellé au
gouvernement
les faits sont gravissimes pour autant
cette affaire ne doit pas être l'arbre
qui cache la forêt il existe un autre
pays une maltraitance e structurelle de
nos aînés qui interroge les politiques
conduites en matière de dépendance
depuis 30 ans en dépit des plans
gouvernementaux successifs les
financements publics n'ont pas été au
rendez vous ils ne sont pas non plus
depuis cinq ans alors que les
professionnels ne cessent de vous
alerter sur un taux d'encadrement
insuffisant sur des conditions de
travail dégradées sur leurs difficultés
à prendre en charge dignement les
personnes âgées qu'ils accueillent c'est
sur ce terrain propice que se sont
engouffrés une poignée de grands groupes
avec la bénédiction des pouvoirs publics
ils représentent désormais 20% des
places en ehpad et dégagent d'énormes
bénéfices sur le dos des salariés et des
usagers
eric revel andré chassaigne qui qui
pointe du doigt plusieurs problèmes un
déjà de la maltraitance structurelle à
répétition et surtout l'impuissance et
l'incompétence quasiment des
gouvernements successifs
est-ce qu'ils pointent tout simplement
un scandale d'état
écouter tout ce qui est excessif est
insignifiant d'avoir évidemment il faut
il faut rendre hommage et à ce
témoignage qu'on a entendu tout à
l'heure parce que toute situation
particulière de ce niveau de
maltraitances sans doute nous touche
directement parce que on a probablement
douce une grand mère peut être une mère
peut être un nom ou une tante qui qui
sont dans ce genre d'établissement donc
évidemment on a un rapport à ce secteur
de la dépendance et des résidences
seniors qui est tout à fait particulier
et humain puisque par définition on est
touchés on sera touché par par ce genre
de choses et quand on entend ces
témoignages évidemment ne peut que
s'inquiéter mais ce que j'aimerais
répondre au député chassaigne c'est que
quand il dit y a
vingt pour cent des lits qui appartient
des groupes privés ça veut dire que le
restant n'appartient pas à des groupes
privés c'est à dire qu'en france il faut
le savoir il ya 6 % de la population de
plus de 65 ans qui réside dans ce type
d'établissement ça concerne c'est le 128
mille personnes dans le pays et environ
dix mille 600 établissements mais ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que 50% des
ehpad son public d'abord première chose
son public monsieur chassaigne l'a
oubliée donc publics bars ça dépend de
l'état des financements de l'état et du
contrôle de l'état sur le restant qui
est privé vous en avez 30 31 % de ces
ehpad qui sont privées certes mais à but
non lucratif qui sont gérés par des
associations donc on se dit c'est pas la
course aux dividendes et au profit
capitaliste tel que le décrit monsieur
chassaigne et enfin effectivement il ya
24 % de groupes privés qui versent des
dividendes à leurs actionnaires
mais qui ne sont que 20 24% dans la
totalité des 100 % que présente ce type
de résidence donc pardonnez-moi mais
vouloir en faire une sorte de procès
politique de récupération politique sur
un sujet outil aussi sensible qui nous
touche autant encore une fois parce
qu'on a une grand mère parce qu'on a une
mère parce qu'on a un nom comme temps
qu'on va voir le week-end et qu'on
n'oublie pas à l'autre pomme d'offres à
l'autre bout de la france c'est un peu
un petit me semble-t-il de faire de la
récup politique mais le sujet la
dépendance un sujet européen
l'accroissement de la vie aujourd'hui
fait qu'il ya plus en plus de gens qui
seront amenés à aller dans ce type
d'établissement alors certes il faut il
faut revoir en france et ailleurs aussi
un les problèmes ils sont pas aussi en
italie en espagne vous savez il ya deux
pays où le ou le domaine privé beaucoup
plus important qu'en france dans les
ehpad c'est l'allemagne et la grande
bretagne mais vous avez des pays comme
les nôtres ou pratiquement la moitié ou
un peu plus sont du domaine public donc
il faut revoir ça sent de fond en comble
il faut peut-être mettre en place un
organisme de contrôle structurelles qui
n'existe pas dans notre pays ça c'est
vrai il ya eu un comité de vigilance
qu'elle était mis en place par xavier
bertrand
quand il était ministre de la santé mais
quelque chose de structurel qui
régulièrement viendrait contrôler ce qui
se passe dans les ehpad ça c'est une
chose mais encore une fois c'est fanny
en faire un débat politique entre les
méchants capitalistes et les gentils du
public si c'était aussi simple et si la
maltraitance était que d'un côté ça
serait aussi enfin jacques myard il
n'empêche problèmes structurels qui
revient quand même souvent sur le tapis
l'impuissance des gouvernements on va
voir justement eric revel nous en parler
à ses investissements la carte des
investissements des ehpad en europe la
france est effectivement
née pourtant l'un des premiers un pays
européens à investir mais par exemple
dans le capital du groupe orpea le plus
gros actionnaire un fonds de pension
canadien on y trouve également
d'ailleurs le groupe peugeot 1 pas
vraiment de rapport entre ces
investisseurs et les établissements
d'hébergement pour personnes âgées
indépendantes
quand jean castex on parle davantage de
contrôles notamment sur les
accréditations il n'ya pas quand même un
effort à faire à ce niveau là jacques
myard écoutez je vais vous dire une
chose lorsque l'établissement
ouvre pour accueillir des personnes
âgées il y a bien sûr tout un dossier à
remplir et il y à des contrôles il faut
que ça réponde à des normes notamment en
matière de sécurité en matière
d'encadrement
c'est ce qui se passe pour vous cacher
dans ma ville où j'ai pratiquement 5 e
et pad certains médicalisé d'autres non
ce qui est certain c'est que ce qui peut
faire c'est revenir régulièrement voir
et contrôler parce qu' il peut y avoir
des dérives dont j'ai entendu sur un
certain nombre de radios que c'était
bien sûr un système qui faisait du fric
et donc il faut éviter que le fric près
2000 et supplante l'humanisme donc de ce
côté là c'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure il ne faut pas se laisser je
dirais subjugué par une autorisation
pour toujours il faut y revenir il faut
vérifier et je suis certain que c'est
possible
ce que l'on peut reprocher à ce
témoignage que nous avons attendu c'est
qu'on ne bâtit pas je dirais une
sanction une démonstration que tout est
foireux parce que il y a pu ce qu'a
rapporté par la maille est il faut ce
n'est pas un quinqua enfin voyons ça
fait quand même longtemps qu'on en parle
il ya eu ce livre écrit effectivement
c'est pas qu'un témoignage qu'on isole
son match n non là il faut pas de
mauvaise foi tout de même cependant je
suis désolé de vous dire on se calme
c'est il peut y avoir un digne âge
regardez ce que cela
ait ramené au nombre de personnes qui
sont dans les ehpad qu'ils soient
publics ou qu'ils soient privés donc de
on il faut se calmer on est en train de
monter en épingle une réalité qu'il faut
corriger mais il ne faut pas je dirais
amalgamer l'ensemble du système c'est
indigne et donc vous savez je vous dire
lorsque j'ai fermé la fameuse maison qui
était absolument
inadmissible c'était effectivement une
boîte privée mais il n'en demeure pas
moins qu'ils compris dans le public vous
pouvez avoir des mouvements c'est une
question de formation du personnel c'est
une question où il faut être vigilant et
je me félicite que le gouvernement veut
mettre en place une structure qui va
être je dirais continuelle mais il faut
se garder mon jacques myard en tout cas
a réagi à chaud évidemment sur une
actualité eric revel justement en termes
de dépendance ont prononcé le mot
c'était aussi une des promesses de
campagne en restait pas le seul
d'ailleurs avant lui d'autres mais enfin
promesse de campagne d'emmanuel micro
quel est le bilan
le bihan il est pas bon le bilan n'est
pas bon parce que le président
république effectivement 2017 avait
promis une grande loi sur la dépendance
il en a reparlé en 2020 mais la remise
dans sa poche cette loi au prétexte que
il y avait des choses plus urgentes à
traiter bon la crise sanitaire la
réforme des retraites ce qu'on peut
remarquer c'est que la crise sanitaire
est toujours là qu'à réforme des
retraites n'a pas été fait mais que
surtout cette grande loi sur la
dépendance qu'avait promise aux 6,1 un
autre dans un autre temps nicolas
sarkozy est toujours dans les cartons et
juste un mot quand même sur
l'actionnariat stéphanie si vous
permettez vous citiez tout à l'heure les
actionnaires d'orpea qui sont des fonds
de pension donc on se dit fonds de
pension c'est évidemment une recherche
du profit maximum mais si vous prenez un
autre très grand groupe d'ehpad comme le
groupe korian je regardais ses
actionnaires c'est le crédit agricole ou
malakoff humanis ce sont des boîtes
françaises qui voilà qui accompagne ce
sont des banques et des assurances mais
je veux dire ce sont des français qui
accompagnent le développement et les
investissements du groupe korian france
donc ce qui est un peu gênant dans tout
ça et je rejoins le point de jacques
myard ce qui est un peu gênant c'est que
évidemment ça nous touche directement
parce qu'encore une fois il n'y aurait
qu'un seul cas comme celui ci il serait
extrêmement choquant parce que ça
pourrait nous toucher directement notre
mère notre grand-mère ou ne tente c'est
n'ya pas le sujet mais ce qui est un peu
choquant c'est que j'ai l'impression que
là on est en train de battre tous dans
le même sac il ya sept cent trente mille
personnes âgées qui vivent dans ces
nuits là il ya des abus il ya des
maltraitances de toutes sortes c'est
indéniable mais voyez on est en train de
jeter aux orties ce secteur alors que
finalement qu'est-ce qu'on a d'autres
comme choix avec l'allongement de la
durée de vie le ce le soin à domicile
certes mais le soin à domicile s'est pas
non plus extensible il faut du personnel
il faut aussi des contrôles qu'est-ce
qu'on a d'autres
possibilités pour essayer d'emmener le
plus loin possible nos chers aînés mais
ce genre d'établissement donc ils font
les contrôler mais on va pas inventé
l'eau chaude du jour au lendemain et
cette espèce de bric à brac dans lequel
on est rentré avec ce bruit médiatique
autour d'un délit les fossoyeurs pour ne
pas le citer c'est un c'est un point
important mais comme toujours gardons
nous de tous les amalgames parce que ça
mais nous pierre si merci messieurs on
est on est présente à 21h30 merci à tous
les deux en tout cas d'avoir participé à
ce décryptage